my friends welcome to mayonnaisegate
we'll give it the funniest name we can
mayo gate
this is a story from wxii
winston-salem restaurants struggling due
to inflation caused by pandemic experts
blame inflated prices on high demand due
to the pandemic
high demand and low supply why is there
a low supply because in april 4 million
people quit their job they're calling it
the great resignation why are people
quitting their jobs because they don't
have to pay rent and because they are
getting 16 an hour on average from
unemployment payments that's not
literally every single person who quit
their job doing it for that reason but a
large reason is this when people don't
need to work to get money and they don't
need to pay rent they say to themselves
maybe i should do something else and be
more fulfilled i can respect not wanting
to work crappy jobs
but when people don't work they don't
make stuff when there's no stuff there's
low supply and the demand raised remains
the same prices will start going up now
many of these media organizations are
trying to obfuscate this they don't want
people to realize it is the fault of
democrat policies and joe biden's
administration so they'll do everything
in their power to lie cheat and steal
and the worst thing about it is this
story really grinds my gears because
they're they're attacking for no good
reason a local restaurant in north
carolina that didn't even get political
this is manet's gate how hilarious and
sad here's what happened
they say
wxii spoke with the owner of the
sherwood a family-owned restaurant in
winston-salem pete straits uh the owner
to find out how much trouble inflation
has caused he says that an increase in
prices has put his business in a
difficult situation quote you can only
offset so much in this business and it
seems like every year you lose here you
lose there i'll give you an example i'm
paying 200 more a week in mayonnaise
now when i saw this story it was because
a bunch of democrat-aligned media
figures
were mocking the restaurant and calling
them liars saying if prices went up by
five point four percent that would mean
that two hundred dollars would that
would equal three thousand seven hundred
thousand mayonnaise per per week
because these people seem to think that
the price increase is static across all
products because they have no idea how
the economy works surprise surprise when
they try and push communism or socialism
what really happened because i called
the restaurant and asked them to clarify
on this uh one of the partners simply
said oh yeah you know we we do about 10
buckets per week they're five gallons
each and they used to be about 18 now
they're 36 so you do the math it's you
know 18 bucks and times 10 it's about
200 and i went makes sense to me and he
said we use the mayonnaise for our
dressings and things like that and
anybody who knows who worked in the
restaurant industry knows you go through
a lot of of
ingredients
like
well all of these here's what we end up
getting
we have this from indy 100 republicans
tried to attack joe biden over the price
of mayonnaise and the responses were
hilarious
they're saying things like here look
posting on twitter the official branch
of the party shared a story in which
restaurateurs expressed dis mayo about
the price of mayo what
yes saying there were they were spending
more than two hundred dollars a week on
it and claimed this was due to bite
inflation the restaurant never said that
that's a lie the restaurant never blamed
joe biden for this but indy is cl is
saying restaurateurs blamed by inflate
by inflation the north carolina
republicans must have been too hangry
and lacking in egg nutrients to notice
however the article they share the uh
they shared quoted experts who blame the
carnivorous pandemic on inflation and
not on biden here's here's what we have
from uh from the independent this from a
different writer gop ridiculed for
bizarre biden mayonnaise smear something
might be happening with mayo consumption
in north carolina these people didn't
bother doing a simple google search
calling a restaurant getting a quote and
saying how much mayonnaise is normal for
a restaurant to use we also have the
huffington post
republicans attempt to smear biden over
mayonnaise gets creamed on twitter how
much mayo can one restaurant use in a
week anyway and you get all your normal
culprits aaron rupar everybody knows
aaron rupar yeah there's a there's a
verb it's called rupar to rupar someone
what's the definition to take something
out of context and mischaracterize to
falsely frame a story what designer drug
is mayonnaise code for
jonah blank says somebody's eating way
too much mayonnaise
then i don't i don't care for these
regular you know this guy who works at
facebook said just imagine the heroic
amounts of mayo this restaurant must be
going through
these people are a combination of
ignorant
arrogant and aggressive and that that is
is shockingly terrifying because what
does that mean they're too stupid to
understand how basic economics works why
a restaurant might need 50 gallons of
mayonnaise per week which probably does
the restaurant capacity i also reached
out 250 people
you get 250 people at one time in a
restaurant during a waitlist period and
you've all seen a weight you've all had
a waitlist at a restaurant how much
mayonnaise you think they're going to
use for 250 people in a 30 minute period
and now how many people are coming to
the restaurant every day could be a
thousand
yeah instead here's what ends up
happening they all end up lying uh
saying mayo flation
mocking the restaurant and it turns into
something much more terrifying when
people start going to their yelp and
saying things like one star review way
too much mayonnaise just mayo everywhere
or one star review too much mayonnaise
used to love the place but mayo is too
much and so i'm told
by the the the owner
at first they were like oh this is silly
what's going on this is we're getting
trolled or something and then he said
that this morning you know it got so
intense he starts getting scared he's
all these reviews are coming in you know
it's something something is happening
and he's scared about what's going to
happen
they're trying to make it seem like this
guy a regular guy who was not involved
in politics insulted joe biden and lied
about his the prices to make him look
bad and now these lunatics are actually
trying to cause damage to this
restaurant who is not political i have
said it before and i will say it again
if you think sitting down and hiding is
going to get you out of whatever is
going on you are wrong and all that's
going to happen is this will be th this
will be life for everyone you'll be
sitting in your your little cafe and
you're like i just run a small business
i have nothing to do with politics and i
don't want to be involved and then one
day antifa will show up and throw a
brick through your window because
someone accused you of being racist
we've seen stuff like that happen in
berkeley the people have to put signs in
all their windows i was in i was in i
was in berkeley for uh some protest
event and there was a nail salon with
you know all of this leftist signage in
the windows and i'm like there's there's
no way
these working-class women who are in
there
immigrants are that adamant about their
activism and so i went to a bar
and as i'm sitting at the bar i'm eating
a burger there was a big thing on the
window that insulted trump and said that
he was some kind of turd or something
and i asked the bartender i was like all
right what's you know everybody has
these signs in the window you know yours
is like you know more insult more more
derogatory and she's like yeah you know
you have to do it and i was like so you
don't do you agree with that message
like are you guys like anti-trump and
she said no
if you don't do it they'll smash your
windows
that's what it's like living in in the
bay area there was a burger king i saw
this was this was back in i think 20
2015 or 2016. a burger king had a big
sign in the window and it said please do
not destroy our windows we are a
family-owned restaurant franchise not a
corporate location
that's what life is like when you let
these people keep doing this stuff
during the the i think it was the was it
the g20 or was it the g7 i don't know it
was in hamburg
they went around smashing up storefronts
and there's this photo of all of these
stores smashed up except for one and do
you know why that one store wasn't
smashed up it had the communist fist in
the window
this is an attack on a regular regular
regular family guy
this is the stuff that i've been saying
they will keep doing
and they and people want to act like i
guess
out of the 300 or so you know 320
million people in this country
excluding the children so you got maybe
250 people how many of them you know uh
are adults
yeah maybe maybe you'll you'll you'll
you'll be safe you'll be lucky maybe as
you know you're in the crowd and the
bear starts charging in you're like i
can run faster than everybody else maybe
you'll be the one person but man you
could stand up right now and tell these
people to shut up
call out the media for lying and going
after regular people who are not
political punching down as hard as they
can
or you can sit back and let your
children inherit this future
so i tweeted about this the other day i
said um
i said something about winston churchill
and his quote about feeding the
alligator and i said at this point
conservatism has become nothing but
feeding the alligator because all we're
doing is saying i just want to be left
alone just let me do my own thing i just
want to grill right that's like the meme
you can't do that anymore like you don't
have a choice and i also tweeted
something inflammatory about how it is
now your role to fight you don't get to
have your white picket fence you don't
get to necessarily have your american
dream because um it's being thwarted by
the far left and this crazy people in
the media and your role right now is to
figure out what you're gonna do about it
and i think until people figure that out
we're gonna have a serious problem we
can't just keep sitting back and taking
it but that's what conservatives do
why
yeah well this story is more disgusting
than a mayo sandwich let me just put it
that way i'm marinating in it and i'm
listening to tim but what what really
jumps out to me is that the democrats a
long time ago lost any pretense that
they care about the little man they are
not up for the real victims in society
they're the victimizers in the society
they obfuscate that by with their
grievance politics their identitarian
politics that they continually shuffle
out but they don't care about the folks
getting shot in chicago
anything that goes against their agenda
against their narrative they either
ignore it downplay it or attack people
who draw attention to it and this poor
guy in north carolina who's just trying
to put food on his family's table uh
just trying to run a small businessman
is extremely difficult due to a lot of
the policies and democrat run states the
lockdown policies where are them
championing the little guys the small
business owners jeff bezos and amazon
raking it in hand over fist this entire
time they don't scrutinize how it's
benefiting corporations and
multi-billionaires uh they don't draw
attention to it they forget they're the
forgotten man this guy in north carolina
he's the forgotten man in society he's
just one example of countless that you
can draw attention to of just grabbing
what looks to be a ludicrous headline
and their lack of compassion for in lack
of sympathy for this small business
owners who's obviously struggling is
illustrated by the fact that they're not
sympathetic with him he's like oh it
must be very difficult not only is it
democrat policies and joe biden's
administration that are responsible for
the inflation but the people who voted
him are gloating and mocking you and
laughing as you struggle through the
muck they're the ones who threw the
sewage on the floor and they're laughing
as you slip in it now let me explain
because it may be a lot of people saying
it's not it was inflation not joe biden
extended unemployment benefits people
are getting 16 bucks an hour not to work
we've already heard from many experts
that this is a a pull a push factor and
so a lot of people don't want jobs and
the response we get from many of the
democrat establishment activists is yeah
well people shouldn't work these crappy
jobs anyway and they should pay better
so it's an acknowledgement we know so
long as you give people the benefits if
they don't have to work they won't
you've got the the eviction moratorium
people aren't paying rent some people
are a lot of people are paying rent but
some people aren't this means that there
is now a bottleneck where retirees and
mom and pop landlords people who own one
building and rent out their basement
can't make ends meet this ripples across
the board
you've also got just
you've got the gas shortage caused by a
worker shortage caused by those factors
which causes all prices to go up so
inflation across the board is on the
rise so long as joe biden wants to enact
illegal eviction moratorium so long as
he wants to uh extend these benefits and
it's not just him it's the
administration the democrats and so long
as he wants to shut down a gas pipeline
which caused speculators to buy more i'm
not a fan of speculators by the way
causes them to buy more driving up
prices and then shut down fracking on
federal land which causes speculators to
predict short supply which increases
speculation and causes price to go for
gasoline these are factors caused by joe
biden directly his policies his
administration and democrats i am no fan
of the republican party i think they're
trash most americans actually have a
worse view of republicans than democrats
but the democrats are the ones who are
doing this right now so i tell you this
i feel bad for this restaurant
i'm also kind of frustrated with with
with with people like this these
restaurants
i can't expect him to have known what
was going on
but if you think that you can sit back
and ignore the world around you and then
you will be safe when the fires or the
storm comes i'm sorry that's just not
true all that is required for evil to
triumph is for good men to do nothing
and so you have i talked to the guy i
talked to two of the people at the
restaurant got a comment
and you know their sentiment was we
don't want to be involved in politics i
think both sides are bad both parties
suck and both sides are doing it and i
said i told him
the right the anti-establishment types
these aren't the people who are
attacking your restaurant right now
because you expressed a fact about your
prices
so if these if regular people don't wake
up to these extremists by all means we
the alt-right they've been gone for
three years nobody likes them i get it
now we have a cult-like authoritarian
left that is going to attack anybody who
says a fact that goes against their
narrative or for no reason at all as we
saw with the black lives matter and
antifa right it's all last year they
attacked other black small business
owners directly burned them to the
ground uh bashed their windows and i
really liked what you said about hanging
signs uh in your door just kind of as
kind of a totem or a sign when i when i
go to this lily white neighborhoods in
westchester county i see black lives
matter sign uh everywhere i don't think
it's because they sincerely believe in
this neo-marxist organization uh i think
it's a totem it's like a jewish passover
where you put the blood on your on your
door and you want people to leave you
alone i did a little social experiment
uh they had a church right next to a
school and they had all these black
lives matter signs and all of their
little punch phrases like love is love
etc etc you know typical maoist type
brainwashing sort of things that they
put on the side i took a sign i ordered
it myself and i put i believe in racial
equality i believe in freedom of speech
i believe in and i listed all of these
different freedoms on there that i you
know just from the constitution and put
it out there you know basically to
provide some kind of contrast and i just
put it right in the middle of the signs
and just waited and i took a picture and
i came came back guess what they had
taken the sign and they got rid of it
because they are not for equality
they're for equity and that means the
government controlling all social
relations
uh in this country and so no you're not
gonna be safe
the the coveted passports all of the
stuff they are we're not used to this
sort of in your face intrusion but it's
going to get worse because as you can
see uh you know and nobody is safe it's
gonna be like the social credit score in
china that you were talking oh yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you